heather is held back at work because
what happens is when she has to have a
really difficult conversation when
there's something that she wants to talk
to her boss about when there's a
conflict with one of her colleagues you
ever have a conflict with your
colleagues at work ever feel like you
work in a toxic work environment well
this is something that you need to
understand sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment is about the other
people and sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment or in your life
environment or your friend environment
is about stored memories in your body
from your childhood i know it's crazy
stuff because the saying feel the fear
and do it anyway it's true because your
body feels situations that put you in a
state of being afraid before your mind
catches up and starts thinking about
what you're afraid of and so one of the
key takeaways from take control and one
of the things that i want to teach you
today is that if you start to tune into
your body and you start to notice the
signals that your body is sending to you
in your day-to-day life signals like
butterflies in your stomach signals like
feeling a rush of energy up to your neck
signals like your armpit sweating
signals like your hands getting sweaty
signals that your body is stepping and
noticing a situation that reminds it of
your past learning how to read those
signals that oh my god here goes my body
my body is starting to recognize that
this is a situation that puts me on edge
recognizing those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my god that
is a critical skill in taking control of
your life stop thinking that you should
be fearless if you go through life
fearless that means you are playing
small and not doing anything that is
worth doing you should be dreaming big
you should be pushing boundaries and in
that push comes fear instead of trying
to be fearless adopt a mindset that you
want to feel the fear and do it anyway
otherwise you will never take on big
projects and you'll never accomplish
your mission and you'll always live
below the potential that you know you're
capable of so just came back from
speaking in phoenix with with dean
graziosi brendan burchard eric thomas
1500 people amazing session my greatest
fear is disappointing people my greatest
fear is i'm going to get on stage and
bomb and disappoint the people who are
paying money to be there as an expensive
ticket to get in
and also i'm going to disappoint dean
graziosi and brendan burchard and people
who brought me here to speak right it's
their event
and i have to be the last speaker on the
last day to come in and and give them a
good performance right i don't want to
let them down we've never worked
together before these are the thoughts
that are going through my head
and so i'm backstage
and actually the first day i get there
i'm i've got the next day right i've got
my whole day ahead of me and i'm going
to speak the next day and then i get a
call so i'm in my hotel room and i'm
practicing i get a call and said hey
evan can you come down right now
we might want to have you speak right
now let's figure it out and in my head's
like right
now i thought i was going on tomorrow
i was in the middle of practice saying i
haven't even gone through the second
half of my my speech
but the default reaction is yep
i'm on my way
and i run downstairs to get to the event
they end up saying it's okay we want you
back on tomorrow usual time perfect no
problem
so now i got the whole night to prepare
again i wake up the next morning i'm
preparing in the morning and then i'm
getting down down to the stage and
initially i'm supposed to go on at 9am
and then that then it got switched to 10
am then that got switched to 11am and
then they want to
take off 10 minutes of my time because
we're a little bit behind from 15
minutes into 60 minutes and then
changing my deck changing the slide that
i have and then i'm sitting backstage
and i'm waiting to come on and it feels
like the mc's
he's building me up and he's taking
lots of time to introduce me like just
bring me on
right and every time
i'm sitting there
worried stressed out
afraid
saying that it's hard this is difficult
i'm afraid
my heart's beating out of my chest
because i'm still thinking i don't want
to go up there and disappoint people
but instead of
being fearless it's like no i'm afraid
and this is the best
because everything i want is on the
other side of this sphere
and i'm going to go off and i'm going to
do the best that i have
and every new thing that comes at me
they kept saying man you're so easy to
work with you're so easy going yep
meanwhile like i'm panicking you're
freaking out inside
and it's not it's not about putting on a
show it's not about showing people that
i'm i'm afraid
it's about me telling myself that i do
difficult things
some people say when you are nervous
tell yourself that you're excited
because it's the same feeling inside you
that when you're about to go on stage or
have a big call or do something that
you're afraid to do you're nervous tell
yourself you're excited i don't want
that
i tell myself i'm nervous
and i do things that make me nervous i
love that i do things that make me
nervous i build my self-esteem and
self-respect and sell pride from jumping
in on the things that make me nervous
you want to do things that make you
nervous
and so i got on stage
and and
did a pretty good job we had a little
miscommunication on the ending and uh
flubbed it a little bit but
i get backstage and brendon burchard's
running back like oh my god you crushed
it so much energy i love that guy and
now i'm on to the next thing
and if there's nothing in my calendar
ahead that is scary difficult hard that
makes me feel afraid
then i'm not growing
and you're not growing too so i've got a
three-step process that i'm going to
walk you through that can help you step
into your fears that i think will help
step number one is understand what is
your big mission what are you trying to
accomplish what is the big mission that
you're on i want to solve the world's
biggest problem i want to spread more
belief i think the world's biggest
problem is there aren't enough people
who believe in themselves and their
michael jordan level talent that's what
i'm helping every single dude every
single do every single day for the rest
of my life that is my mission
what is your big mission what is the
thing that you're afraid of doing what
is that giant thing right now me
stepping on stage at brendan and dean's
event make sense because i'm trying to
spread my mission what is your big
mission number two is what's the next
step that you're afraid to take
if you want to go off and have a big
impact change a lot of lives you're
gonna have to do things you've never
done before because the way you're doing
it now the growth that you're on now is
not fast enough you're not going to hit
your target it's not going to happen
it's going to require a bolder more
confident more courageous version of you
and how do you get that by stepping into
the light
by stepping into your nerves
by stepping into your fears that's how
you grow that's how you emerge stronger
so what's the next step for you your big
mission just came up with it step number
one what's your big mission great what
is the next step that you must take to
move that mission forward that you are
afraid of and then step number three is
commit to doing it right now
commit to doing it right now you are not
allowed anymore to think of something
that's big that's exciting that it that
is
game changing for you that gets you
pumped up ready to go you're not allowed
to think of that and then be afraid and
then not do something
you need to stop teaching yourself that
that you come up with ideas
then you get afraid and then you don't
have momentum
and you play small you need to break
that cycle so we've just gone through it
you came up with your big mission you
came with what the next step is now you
need to commit to doing it commit to
someone else that you're gonna do it
make a video talking about it send that
email you need to send out text the
person that you need to text post it to
your facebook or instagram tell people
that you're gonna do this thing commit
while you're feeling it right now
and then you feel your heart beating
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom you're scared you're gonna wake up
tomorrow's like holy cow what did i just
commit they're doing
you're committed to doing the thing that
you're a badass at because you're
chasing down a dream because you have a
big vision because you don't want to
play small for the rest of your life
because you're ready for this
that's why you committed now let's go
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
there is no fast track to transformation
you have to work on it in little ways
every day you can't buy self-esteem or
self-love you must build it you must
stand face to face with the part of you
that you hate
you must forgive yourself for the hurt
that you've caused especially the hurt
you've caused yourself
and then you got to do the work to
become a better you
it's the only way to create the
self-respect and build the self-esteem
that you want you can change there are
do-overs in life because you get one
every single morning when you wake up
look in the mirror and decide who you're
going to be today you can choose you can
change no you can't go back in time but
you can have your own back as you use
the time that you have now
to take control and create a new chapter
that makes you proud of who you are
the hardest part of all this is flipping
your focus
from what you hate and are trying to fix
toward what you want to create
remember the windshield in a car is
bigger than the rear view mirror for
good reason you're not supposed to go
backwards you're supposed to drive your
life forward and that means you must
start looking
ahead yeah you've screwed up me too the
worst things that you've done witnessed
or survived they are your most powerful
teachers so stop making yourself wrong
about what happened and unpack it
understand it
face yourself in the mirror and learn
the lessons that are woven into every
mistake
every regret you ever have and every
painful thing you've ever experienced
here's the profound insight i gained
that i want you to hear you aren't
broken
you're just blocked
forgive yourself for all the things you
did while you were just trying to
survive your mind collects mental lint
that's right that's all that doubt is
that's all that fear is that's all that
anxiety is that's all that worry is it's
all the people pleasing is
this is lint from life that is collected
in your brain and you know what lint
stands for something get your pencils
ready
you lose inspiration
due to negative thoughts
that's all that's happening
you're not broken you're just blocked
the filter in your mind is blocked just
like a dryer filter gets blocked by lint
and you can't think this stuff away you
got to take action
and the single most effective tool on
the planet hands down
to wipe away the lint in your mind to
wipe away the doubt to wipe away the
fear to wipe away the anxiety
is the five second rule
i'm dead serious about this
when you feel
the fear rise up when you feel the
self-doubt start to block
when you feel the anxiety start to take
over when you feel like you're losing
the inspiration to move you're just
gonna count backwards five four three
two one
i know it sounds dumb
but trust me on this one counting
backwards five four three two one wipes
the lint
off the filter in your brain
that lint that makes you lose your
inspiration to act due to negative
thoughts
and once you get to one it's clear
so your confidence and your courage can
flow right through you this one is like
really important
you need to do the work okay
you gotta do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain
and you go i don't think i want to do
this because i don't think i feel like
doing this and next thing you know you
are back in the car driving back down
the road to that little diner that you
saw and instead of climbing the mountain
that you've always dreamt of climbing
you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also been putting
in the time every day consistently to
not only see yourself
walking
up that trail step by step but that you
have felt yourself pushing through the
resistance the fear the obstacles the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud
that's how you use manifesting to get
what you want that's how you leverage
all the science and research to train
and prepare your mind body and spirit to
help you get what you want and that's
how you hack the motivation and
inspiration that you need to take the
actions that get you everything that you
want and deserve in life the dallas uber
driver oh so as somebody who has gotten
into
countless ubers and some small
percentage of them know who i am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um i get choked up when i
think about him
uh an aha moment choked up
i get choked up
because what happens for me every single
day
is and you hear from people every single
day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content there are people out there
that
use your work as a lifeline
and it is humbling
and what i am
really present to
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back
and how much pain people feel
because most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy
arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough i
failed so many times i can't go through
that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you
and you are actively arguing against it
you're bringing yourself down you're
beating yourself out like people will
cheer for you and me they won't cheer
for themselves
i'm the same way
and so this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then
uh was promptly fired after season one
it was a huge failure because we didn't
make it to season two
huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says
i have a dream of being a oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and latino men to do the
same in acting and i'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
dallas
right yeah the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
in la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not
and he says i have 700 in my bank
account i'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have seven hundred dollars
in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and i write about it
in this book
where i am actively arguing for his
dream and he is actively arguing against
his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right 700 could get me there
you're right i am only 25. you're right
if i keep thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about what i want
to be doing i'm not only going to drive
in circles my whole life is going to
spin in circles as i think about what i
want and i don't do [ __ ] about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves
you must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal
this is a major mistake that people make
they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal
if you've ever made a vision board
think about what you put on the vision
board you put up just the beach house or
the million dollars in the bank are you
crossing the finish line are you
launching that business or you having
the body that you want are you a driving
the maserati whatever it is the end goal
is what you put up on a vision board
that is not what you're going to do when
you manifest if you start focusing on
crossing the finish line of the marathon
that is a one-way ticket to being
unmotivated and completely discouraged
in fact research shows that if all you
do is focus on the thing that you want
and you just focus on that vision of you
and your bikini body or you with the
love of your life on your arms or you at
the
oscars winning that award or the grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal
you start to feel really unmotivated and
discouraged because you're nowhere near
it
that's where manifesting comes in
because we're not going to focus on the
end goal
you got to pick something that you want
in order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end
it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be
but when it comes to manifesting
once you've given yourself permission to
dream with the lid off and really want
what you want to feel the pull of that
thing now we got to talk about the path
that connects where you are with where
you want to go
and this is all about visualizing the
little steps there's a lot of research
that proves why visualizing the steps
is
the most important thing that you could
do
there was a study done at ucla for
example
where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a
close their eyes visualize in their mind
and feel in their body
themselves taking the test
and then walking up
to a board where the tests
scores were posted
and finding their name and seeing an a
plus
that's what group a the vision board
group were told to do
to visualize themselves achieving what
they wanted
group b we're going to call these the
hard workers these students were coached
in this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room
sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late
and putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test was it group a the
vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it group b
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered group b
you got the correct answer the reason
why group b
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it
lowers your resistance and leads to you
taking the action that's why manifesting
works you know the same is true in
sports there's all kinds of research in
sports psychology in fact our olympic
athletes for the u.s olympic team
they hire sports psychologists to train
our top olympic athletes particularly
after they've been injured
in
visualizing themselves competing
when you coach an athlete to mentally
rehearse every single detail about going
through the competition
you are training the mind body and
spirit to show up and dominate this is
particularly true for athletes after
they've been injured and they're
stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right
so manifestation properly remember what
it is manifesting is preparing your mind
body and spirit to do the work it's
aligning your mind body and spirit with
what you want it removes the obstacles
that would normally stop you which then
prepares and motivates you to take the
actions to succeed so in the case of
athletes who visualize themselves and
see themselves doing all the steps over
and over they're removing the nerves
they're removing all the programming
related to the injury they are preparing
their mind body and spirit to go in and
frickin dominate and so are you you know
when you're about to meet a friend
somebody you really like at a cafe
you're gonna go have a cup of tea
what do you feel right before you walk
in the door
excitement enthusiasm energy joy
uh
positive nervousness like that that that
kind of like uh
butterflies even in a positive sense
yeah so at this moment i was 51 years
old
in 51 years of being alive i don't ever
remember
feeling
that feeling about seeing myself wow
for the first time in my life i had this
sensation
that i was excited
to see the human being mel robbins now
i've been excited to see an outfit
or excited to see a haircut
i have never been excited to see the
person
and so i round the corner and this
sense of how profound this is is hitting
me
and i'm standing there
brushing my teeth and i realize
something really wild
there are always two of you in the
bathroom together
there's you
and there is a human being in the mirror
a person who needs you
a person who has been waiting for you to
wake up and realize they are there
and they need you to see them and to
hear them and to love them and to
support them
and so what's interesting because you
brought up morning routines right is
that we all talk about the importance of
setting our day up because it's how it
ends up we talk about gratitude and
meditation and we know the extraordinary
benefits of it
but i don't think anybody has truly
amplified the fact that there is this
dirty habit that we all have
every single morning that is a part of
your morning routine unless you have
weeded this out
and it is a habit of either ignoring
yourself
or
beating the heck out of yourself
every single morning in the mirror i
mean 91 percent of women don't like how
they look 50 of us can't even look at
ourselves in the mirror one of the
things that i think you should always
come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up so
that i'm practicing what i call simple
discipline simple discipline is nothing
more than making and keeping simple
promises to yourself repeating it every
day the way that you start to change the
big things is you change the small
things make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so how do
you build simple discipline here are
some core skills that i do every morning
that have helped me number one
i do not sleep with the phone
number two when the alarm goes off on my
phone it's not near me so i have to get
my ass out of bed i get up i make my bed
i get moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal i take 10 minutes to
myself to plan my day when i do that my
day is incredible i believe that how you
start your day dictates how the day goes
you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you you need to customize this
you are unique i think about how do you
come alive for yourself in the morning
what are the five senses what's the
first thing that you see when you wake
up for me it's a painting that i
manifested out of thin air it reminds me
that what you put your mind to and what
you work toward
it will become a reality i always light
incense because it makes my senses and
my nose come alive i'm super mindful
over what i taste first thing in the
morning my grandma always had vinegar in
the morning with honey and hot water i
picked the one thing that matters to me
today you're a big proponent of the
growth mindset you guys talk about it
all the time on the show right so
researchers wanted to know what is the
most empowering way to motivate kids
through a really big challenge okay they
divide the kids into three groups this
takes the marshmallow test to a whole
other level you got one group of kids
that are doing a challenging task and
they're getting the fixed mindset praise
which we all know does not work oh tom
you're so smart oh tom i love your
glasses that's going to help you oh tom
you got a great smile oh tom you know i
i just love so much about you i know you
can do this so that's one group the
second group gets the growth mindset
kind of phrase tom you are such a hard
worker tom your perseverance is
unbelievable tom you just keep going
that does better obviously than telling
you that you're smart because it makes
you motivated to work hard the third
group
they just got a simple high five the
researchers didn't even say anything to
the kids they just walked up gave them a
high five the group of kids that got a
simple high five outperformed outworked
through all of the challenges all of the
other forms of praise
why
because a high five is something deeper
than praise
it fulfills your most fundamental needs
as a human being
when somebody high-fives you you feel
seen
you feel heard
and you feel like somebody has
acknowledged
you for the unique person that you are
and one of the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting
evidence
as you're doing the work as you're going
through your day it will help you if you
train your mind to start scanning the
world and spotting evidence
that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because
if you get into a negative mindset if
you start thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother i'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should i keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic
negative protective
scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend corinne crabtree always talks
about that transformational moment and
when your mind goes negative your mind
starts to scan the world and will show
you more reasons to stop and the power
of training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple
the power is that your mind will start
to show you reasons to keep going
your mind will help you take the step
your mind will encourage you to feel
optimistic to feel empowered just like
you woke up today on a tuesday and it
was february 22nd
2022 and those numbers are lining up and
that makes you in your heart and soul go
whoa
something cool could happen today like
that only happens like once in my
lifetime those numbers are going to line
up like that today
is a really cool day let's go do
something with this
you could create that kind of attitude
every single freaking day of your life
you could
if you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that i
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why i love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself where
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my god it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a heartbeat
there we go
check that out
if you say
brain
mind show me a heart today guess what's
gonna happen that damn dog biscuit
it's gonna show it's gonna you're gonna
be like there's a heart you're gonna
look out at the sky and you're gonna see
a heart shape oh right there in the
mountains there's a heart shape in the
mountains in southern vermont you're
going to see it in the clouds what
you're doing when you tell your mind
what's important to you is you're
telling your mind and the filter in your
brain to change in real time and allow
into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by god those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me mel robbins on social media you will
see every day i am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this i
don't wanna see all the reasons why i'm
unhappy i don't wanna see
uh everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and i don't want to see that and and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me
i want my mind to reprogram itself and
see other people's businesses and see
other people getting healthy and see
other people in relationships and i want
my mind to say
yeah
if they can do it i can do it that's
evidence if that person can get healthy
so can i if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can i if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can i
other people can become evidence that
you can have it too right now your mind
is so [ __ ] up from your past that when
you see what other people have and you
don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
gonna win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what i wanted that sucks
and so what i want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa
this is a once in a lifetime day
everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it i swear to god
something will
something will
if you want to see the good all around
you you got to tell your mind you want
to see the good and this just isn't a
bunch of horse everybody this isn't
toxic positivity there is a filter in
your brain called the reticular
activating system the reticular
activating system i call it the ras i
like to think about it like a giant hair
net on your head and this ras sits over
your brain i'm probably getting this
wrong i'm not a neuroscientist i could
give about getting it right i just need
you to know the basics here so that you
can apply it to your life okay you don't
need a phd to use the science that super
smart people have been working really
hard on in order to apply it to your
life that's what i'm here for in your
life i'm here to translate this stuff
into simple believable and actionable
things that you can do
to take all this super cool stuff that
people are researching and apply it to
your normal person's everyday life to
help you
change from the inside out and one of
the coolest things that you have at your
disposal is you have
a whole system in your body that you can
train
and change
and one of those things that you can
train and change
that is impacted by that real that word
you're hearing a lot of neuroplasticity
that just means that things are able to
twist and bend and change and you're
able to learn new things for as long as
you're alive
as long as you're breathing everybody
you got a chance to change the way that
you think as long as you are breathing
you got a chance to change from the
inside out how you experience your life
as long as you are still here watching
me people you got a chance to create a
new experience in your life and one of
the things that helps a lot is
understanding that right now all of the
bull from your past has jammed the
filter in your mind body and spirit the
reticular activating system
and it is clouding your ability to look
at the world around you and see
hearts remember this dog treat hearts
look at that there's a heart right there
i had completely forgotten about the
audiobook because i was so
focused on this new york times things
and by the way here's another thing
you can't make the new york times list
if you're a self-published author
something i didn't even know when i
started
so
here i thought i'd fail didn't achieve
my dream the whole thing
i get this email
your monthly report is ready and i'm
like monthly report what are they
talking about
i click on that report i open it up i am
literally like oh
my god
audiobooks
audiobooks
who
knew audiobooks were a thing
here's what happened
the entire time that i kept going
something amazing was happening lisa
they were going to the hardcover but it
wasn't available they bought the only
thing that was available
the audiobook
the five-second rule
became the number one audiobook of the
year lisa
it to this day is the most successful
self-published audio book
in the history of audible
and
it created a brand new partnership that
i have with audible something by the way
that i never
would have had happen had my hardcover
campaign be successful
and here's the other thing i have never
achieved my goal of being a new york
times assigned author and i might never
achieve it
i've never made a traditional bestseller
list
and it proves something that i believe
very deeply and that is that your dreams
and the things that you put on your
vision board have a very important
purpose
they pull you through your fears
they inspire you to take action
but they are not necessarily meant to be
achieved
i believe when you pursue your dreams
and you keep going
and you keep telling yourself that if i
work hard something amazing is going to
happen
you'll achieve something better
something that you don't even know
or
can even think about right now because
it's not even on your radar screen those
dreams are
dots
on the map of your life that pull you in
a direction you're meant to go
but you might never end up there because
you're meant to end up somewhere else
i actually have an incredible quote of
yours about dreams you say when it comes
to your dreams you have two choices
pursue them or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it there are four
techniques that i use whenever i'm gonna
have a difficult conversation that help
me
stay focused on what i need to talk
about instead of getting hijacked by my
emotions number one i always start the
conversation by acknowledging
my responsibility in the mess that we
have to talk about whether it's the fact
that i've avoided dealing with this
sooner or whether there's something that
i've done that's contributed to the
situation i acknowledge it right up
front and one of the reasons why that's
so important is because by accepting
some responsibility you're diffusing the
other person's emotion
you're also honoring them a little bit
and it sets a much more level playing
field for when you get into the
difficult things that you need to talk
about it's also going to put the person
that you're speaking to a little at ease
so they're going to be able to listen
number two you want to have a goal
never go into a difficult conversation
without an outcome defined before you go
into it the reason why the outcome is so
important is because this conversation
is going to be a roller coaster the
person that you're talking to might get
upset you yourself might feel emotional
at some point whether you're angry or
you're triggered or you get sad and so
when you ride the roller coaster of
emotion the thing that is going to
stabilize your thoughts is the outcome
that you're causing you're having this
conversation because you're committed to
making the relationship better you're
having this conversation because this
isn't working and so we need to end it
powerfully you're having this
conversation because you want to give
somebody some feedback that's not so fun
to tell them but you're giving it to
them because you're committed to their
success okay so that goal you feel
yourself getting emotional you come back
to it you come back to it you come back
to it
third thing you're going to do a lot in
this conversation you're going to listen
and you're going to validate
so you're going to say what you need to
say and then the other person's going to
react
and instead of arguing or debating i
want you to listen and i want you to
validate what the person is saying may
sound counterintuitive but honestly one
of the most powerful things you can do
in any conversation whether you're
fighting with your kids over curfew or
you're arguing with somebody at work
over workloads whatever it may be is
here where the person's at
the moment you say wow
that must be really tough
what you're dealing with or
oh i totally get why you now were
avoiding me
if i felt the way that you felt i'd
probably do the same thing
the second you validate somebody they
immediately stop defending themselves
it's unbelievable actually
unbelievable you've got to try it
validate validate validate it is the
most powerful thing and then once of
course they feel validated that you've
heard them now they can listen
and that's when you come back to the
final thing which is you're going to
restate always the outcome keep coming
back to it keep coming back to it
and yeah it's not going to be fun
it's not going to be easy you're going
to have all kinds of emotions come up
because you've been avoiding this
conversation but i'm telling you right
now
if you find the confidence and the
courage to go and to start this thing
knowledge your responsibility have an
outcome in mind validate the other
person validate validate validate and
keep talking until you hit that outcome
you're going to be really really amazed
at how much easier these things become
and if you want to make it even easier
on yourself rehearse it with another
friend first somebody that's not
involved in the situation because again
difficult conversations comes down to
one important thing
the ability for you to separate your
emotion about doing it from the things
you actually need to talk about and the
outcome that you want to cause if you
can't stand in front of the mirror
and raise your hand
and high-five yourself just because you
got your ass out of bed
and you're breathing
you will never get what you want in life
ever there is something in the
resistance to it and if you unpack the
resistance
you will find the reason why you don't
have what you want you either think
you're not worthy of it or you think
that it's kind of stupid or you have
been brought up to believe that
for women in particular you're going to
be [ __ ] or selfish or not likable if
you're celebrating yourself there is
something in the resistance to you
simply
cheering for yourself one of the biggest
objections that people had to
standing in front of the mirror take a
moment look at yourself and then raise
your hand
as people said over and over and over
again
i haven't done anything worthy
of high-fiving
high-fiving feels like a celebration
i don't have the number on the scale
that i want
i don't like my bank account i don't
enjoy what i do for a living i've made a
load of mistakes
i'm struggling with trauma
i don't have anything to celebrate
and what i realized is
people are making a fundamental mistake
you are withholding the very support
empowerment and celebration that you
need to change and to do the hard work
and to face the things that you're
scared of
and that's why
you're not changing when i think back
three years ago where i was like saw one
of your videos or gary's videos or
somebody i'm like oh
i just need to start filming the book
lines at these
and it was a it was a moment it was this
little
amount of wisdom inside of me that i
listened to
and i am telling you that is the power
you got to tune out the noise and you
got to learn how to make what i call a
quiet decision yeah quiet decision where
you shh
you hear what your heart is is urging
you to do let's start with a metaphor
i want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters
some chapters are boring and a grind to
get through and others are exciting and
you hope they never end and right now
you're in a chapter
[Music]
maybe this chapter of your life is a
grind it's overwhelming and unsatisfying
and you feel stuck reading it over and
over again
maybe you want to start a new chapter
but you don't know what the next chapter
is about and so you keep rereading the
one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life
you don't have to know where this next
chapter is going
you just have to start writing it
i want you to envision a blank page
what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself
i don't want you to try to figure out
what job or business you should write on
that page what belongs on that page are
the dreams that you have for yourself
and your life
and all that's required to start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school
yes you should try to launch that
business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate or it's a 20-year
career that you're just burnt out on
or maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this is the moment to write your next
chapter
you're not too late
[Music]
you're right on time
all you need is a blank page
and a pen
do
tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can move your body
because negativity gets stored here and
moving your body we know based on the
research simply moving your body for 10
or 20 minutes a day will release
chemicals in your mind
that help you boost your mood the second
thing that will boost your mood is i
want you to make a tiny promise to
yourself every day just one thing that
makes you feel more positive is it
getting up on time
is it eating something healthy
is it only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail i want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise i want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is
have a zero tolerance policy for your
own negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world i woke up this morning i
looked in the mirror
i looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here
and i started to go negative
i started to feel dreary and i went mel
cut this [ __ ] out you gotta fight to
stay positive gal because we are in this
for another couple months and do not
succumb to despair do not start thinking
native stuff when you have negativity
internally you got to have a zero
tolerance policy for that
it's one thing to feel what you need to
feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating fi the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second negative five four
three two one
not listening to it no i am redirecting
my thoughts that's right i am looking
for the things i can control i am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that i can control right now
today and if you want more fire and
espresso videos check out the one that
we recently did the link is right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there